[Música]
en vídeos anteriores ya hemos hablado
del ninja gaiden 1 y ninja gaiden 2 y
gracias a ustedes y al apoyo que le
dieron a esos vídeos el día de hoy
cerraremos la trilogía moderna de estos
juegazos con el último juego que ha
tenido la saga o sea también esta ya iba
pero la verdad es que el juego es
horrible es decir yo sé que ninja gaiden
3 no es que sea un juegazo precisamente
pero está lado esta cosa es juego del
año hay que pretender que esto nunca
existió quién es más cuál fue en fin
volviendo al tema el día de hoy
hablaremos del ninja gaiden 3 que aunque
tuvo ciertos errores y fallas con
respecto a los dos juegos anteriores es
también un gran juego con algunos datos
interesantes que espero que no conozcas
y que te resulten igual de interesantes
como a mí vamos a ver 10 curiosidades
secretos y detalles de ninja gaiden 3
a pesar de que te habíamos visto el
rostro del río en los juegos para la nes
y en algunos juegos desde ahora live los
juegos de lucha en los que participa de
vez en cuando en este juego es la
primera y única vez que hemos podido ver
el rostro de río en la trilogía moderna
de ninja gaiden
de manera muy similar a los juegos
anteriores en ninja gaiden 3 hay una
forma de conseguir karma infinito
aprovechando te de un pequeño error del
juego ya que si pausas el juego varias
veces antes de recoger un escarabajo ya
sea dorado o plateado y logras pausar en
el momento exacto en el que recoge del
escarabajo comenzarás a recibir una
enorme cantidad puntos
como ya es costumbre en la saga ninja
gaiden 3 tuvo una versión mejorada
llamada razor's edge la cual fue creada
a raíz de las numerosas quejas de los
fans por la falta de sangre y el poco
contenido que el juego ofrecía así que
la versión razor's edge eliminó la
censura e incluyó los desmembramientos y
la sangre vuelta al juego como debe ser
pero además incluye muchas otras cosas
como más variedad de armas personajes
jugables misiones coleccionables que en
general mucho contenido que mejoró
bastante el juego original otro de los
cambios que hizo la versión risos es con
respecto al juego original fue que
eliminaron algunas escenas como por
ejemplo la escena inicial en un
escenario con los ojos rojos asesinando
al padre decana o la escena en donde un
soldado le pide piedad arriba y el
cruelmente lo asesina
yo quiero men
esto es debido a que estas escenas
fueron puestas inicialmente para que
pudiéramos ver que el río tiene un lado
oscuro y malvado el cual luego se vería
reflejado en la maldición de su brazo
pero fueron eliminadas ya que se dieron
cuenta de que ryu hayabusa nunca fue un
personaje cruel y poner estas escenas
resultaban algo bastante incoherente y
fuera el lugar con el personaje así que
decidieron remover las
el tiempo que usa el río en este juego
que le permite convertirse en un
imponente dragón de fuego y eliminar a
todos sus enemigos es una evolución del
arte del infierno que ya habíamos visto
en ninja gaiden 1 y 2 con el cual
podemos lanzar múltiples bolas de fuego
a nuestros enemigos
riu en este juego logró evolucionar su
técnica y convertirla en el arte del
verdadero infierno
como ya mencioné antes la versión
resource sets del juego incluyó entre
muchas cosas coleccionables que estarían
ocultos a lo largo de todo el juego los
cuales son los escarabajos dorados y las
ya conocidas calaveras de cristal pero
curiosamente en este juego las calaveras
son algo distintas ya que se les agregó
una nueva mecánica ya no podríamos
solamente recogerlas como los juegos
anteriores sino que ahora para tomarlas
la veíamos primero completar las pruebas
de valor
un gran detalle que tuvo el juego en su
historia es que cuando el río toma
prestadas para el archi demonio de la
tumba de game in esta no desprende su
brillo escarlata como solía ser esto
pasa ya que la mente del río está
confundida y no se ha ganado el derecho
de blandir la espada pero es puesta que
carga se transforma en esta cosa game in
mediante un sueño al ver que el río poco
a poco comienza a crear su mente de ser
digno de usar su arma con una sonrisa en
su rostro le otorga el alma de la espada
permitiéndole usar todo el poder de la
espada del archi demonio y desde ese
momento la espada vuelve a tomar su
característico brillo
a pesar de que este juego se cambiaron
las icónicas estatuas de dragón que
usábamos para guardar el juego por un
halcón aún podemos ver una de estas
estatuas escondidas en el día 5 cuando
nos adentramos en el bosque
además sabes que el halcón que nos
permitiría guardar la partida en este
juego es una referencia al clan al que
río pertenece ya que él es japonesa
hayabusa significa halcón peregrino
el antagonista principal por la mayor
parte del juego y uno de los personajes
insignia en llegar en tres es el regente
de la máscara que resulta ser un
personaje muy interesante y con un gran
diseño lo cual en parte radica en su
característica máscara que fue basada y
creada a partir del diseño de la máscara
vista en el fantasma de la ópera' al
parecer esta máscara fue creada por
click para reflejar el gusto de su
hermano por el teatro pero además de eso
la máscara regente fue creado
originalmente de esta manera para darle
un aire misterioso y elegancia al
personaje pero agregándole un toque
siniestro a ser tan poco expresiva y
bastante sombría pero está genial diseño
no fue ni idea cerca el primero que fue
creado para el personaje ya que en una
etapa temprana de desarrollo se
barajaron bastantes opciones sobre el
diseño del antagonista principal entre
ellos algunos en donde su máscara
cambiaba ligeramente y se le daba un
toque un poco más medieval al personaje
e incluso algunos muy genial es que no
personalmente gustado verlos en los
cuales el personaje tiene
características más demoníacas y
siniestras involucrando tal vez alguna
transformación que tendría el personaje
en el día 2 justo después de que
perdíamos la espada del dragón por la
maldición del brazo de arriba allá me
aparece de la nada y nos otorga una
espada nueva pero no se nos explica
mucho acerca de esta espada
bueno el nombre de esta espada es bien
raro y pertenece jayate un personaje de
los juegos de dead or alive allá está al
igual que río pertenece un clan ninja y
ambos han sido amigos desde bastante
jóvenes y es por esta misma amistad que
en cuanto vaya te escucho el rumor de
que río había perdido la espada del
dragón e inmediatamente envió su espada
con una llave para que el río la usará
en su viaje aún se desconoce si estás
para al igual que la spag el dragón
tiene alguna habilidad especial pero se
cree que como sugiere su nombre esta
espada podría controlar las tormentas ya
que jim rash maru se traduce como
tormenta rápida todo esto es una manera
bastante curiosa de unir los universos
de dead or alive y de ninja gaiden con
pequeños guiños entre ambas series
finalmente con este vídeo damos cierre a
esta pequeña serie de vídeos dedicados a
la saga de ninja gaiden para mí fue todo
un placer explorar esta genial saga de
videojuegos y verdaderamente espero que
te haya gustado tanto como a mí me gusta
hacerlos por ahora tendremos que esperar
que se anuncie el tan esperado en llegar
en 4 pero mientras tanto si quieres ver
cualquier otro juego en esta serie de
curiosidades y secretos puedes dejar me
tus sugerencias en los comentarios
además de que como es costumbre comenta
tus opiniones de estas curiosidades y de
ninja gaiden en general
crees que vivamos para verte llegar en 4
algún día nos estará leyendo hasta la
próxima
[Música]